thank you so much to the academy for
this
incredible award even to be nominated
amongst these
phenomenal filmmakers is an honor in
itself
and of course there are so many people
that i need to to thank because
you know making a film is the sum of so
much work and so many dreams and there
are so many people behind the film
and i want to express my my profound
gratitude to
everyone involved thank you darius and
abe
the true masters behind this film thank
you sasha and bear for your great
support
thanks to the fantastic visual effects
team who put their blood sweat and tears
into the making of tennis
actually everybody who worked on the
film from soup to nuts
all their individual contributions were
invaluable
i think the winner is definitely the
collaborative spirit
we all share during the making of this
beautiful film
and because the film is about being a
father
as a father i just want to send my my
love to my my sons
gabriel and roman my wife swati
and tom my son who were part of the
production
and supported me through through
everything
my mum and dad my wife jackie max and
ryan for everything
there are lots of other people behind
the scenes who i want to thank but i
better stop now
um i hope you all know who you are
uh thank you thank you big thank you to
everybody
thank you of course last but not least
my fantastic octopus teacher who taught
me
that wild places and wild creatures are
really the most
valuable thing on this whole planet and
that we should do
everything our most important job is the
regeneration
preservation of the wild world
thank you
you